heute zeige ich euch wie man aus süßen
lebkuchenmännchen gruseliges skelett
kekse macht für den teig brauchen wir
180 gramm butter 140 gramm zucker 1 1
der größe m 30 gramm bacau 300 gramm
mehl eine prise salz und fünf gramm
backpulver als erstes verrühren wir die
zimmer warme butter mit dem zucker und
der prise salz in unserer küchenmaschine
die könnte aber auch ein handrührgerät
benutzen
sid
nach ca 3 minuten auf höchster stufe
kommt dann unser eigens und wird nochmal
untergerührt
sobald sich das all gut verbunden hat
kommen die trockenen zutaten hinein
erst sieben wir das mehl und auch das
backpulver als letztes sehen wir noch
den bug auf
jetzt wird alles auf niedriger stufe
miteinander verrührt
sobald ihr merkt dass die küchenmaschine
nicht mehr weiter kneten kann und eine
kribbelige masse entstanden ist nehmt
ihr den teig aus der schüssel und käse
team mit den händen weiter
der keks teig wird jetzt so lange mit
den hinten weiter geknetet bis ein
fester teil entstanden ist
anschließend wollen wir ihn in
frischhaltefolie ein und lassen die
mindestens vier stunden meinem
kühlschrank kühlen
nach der kür zeit nehmen uns die hälfte
des teigs und kneten ihn mit unseren
händen wieder weich
jetzt lege ich mir meinen backpapier
zurecht und außerdem habe ich noch zwei
abstandhalter die habe ich aus dem
baumarkt für einen euro fünfzig da müsst
ihr gar nicht so viel geld ausgeben wie
bewegt nämlich dass der teig gleichmäßig
dick ist jetzt legen wir unseren tag
darauf und dann nochmal backpapier und
jetzt können wir das ganze einmal
ausrollen
ich nehme jetzt meinen lebkuchenmännchen
ausstecher und sticht damit den teig aus
meine ausstecher sind ziemlich groß
deswegen bekomme ich nur zwölf münchen
raus und die lege ich jetzt aufs
backblech
dick
die ausgestochenen kekse kommen jetzt
erst mal für 15 minuten in den
kühlschrank
anschließend müssen sie direkt aus dem
kühlschrank in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 190 grad ober unterhitze für circa
zehn minuten für unser rating habe ich
hier ein eiweiß das ist ganz frisch und
ca 200 gramm die siebten puderzucker
das müssen wir jetzt miteinander
vermischen
das racing sollte vom schneebesen gut
runter fließen und nicht mehr so klumpig
sein
ich habe mir hier einen spritzbeutel
vorbereitet mit einer lok hülle
das müsste die nummer zwei sein von
wilden und natürlich jetzt sv leißing 1
und jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere
lebkuchenmännchen und fangen an sie zu
verzieren
viel spaß beim nachbacken und wenn ihr
mehr davon sehen wollt dann lasst mir
gerne ein abo da